für den poller uns haben paul
thomas wir sind hier immer noch in der
ortschaft in konstantinov da und wir
haben gerade gehört dass russische
truppen 20 kilometer von hier entfernt
hast ja eingenommen haben eine weitere
stadt und jetzt ihr weiter vorrücken in
unsere richtung wir haben von
mörserbeschuss dem schon berichtet der
von weitem zu hören ist in dieser stadt
die fronten ungefähr 50 kilometer
entfernt wir werden jetzt hier von
constantin aufbrechen müssen denn die
russischen truppen kommen in diese
richtung das ist das was wir von unseren
fällen hören das ist das was wir von der
frontlinie hören die situation hier im
donbass das in der ost ukraine
das ist die stelle von der routine von
anfang an gesprochen hat und gesagt hat
das ist eine unabhängige volksrepublik
aus seiner sicht also man rückt weiter
vor hier in richtung der städte die noch
ukrainisch kontrolliert und wie diese
stadt von partie noch da und der wir in
den vergangenen tagen wochen immer
wieder berichtet haben nämlich dann von
der frontlinie und das ist eine
situation die jetzt sehr kritisch zu
werden schalten pauli schnell wird das
jetzt alles gehen wird das tage dauern
oder wird das ja man will das wort
blitzartig in diesem zusammenhang nicht
aussprechen
man hat das gefühl dass hier zumindest
im osten das ist das was wir von unseren
quellen dort hören ist sehr sehr schnell
gehen könnte also dass hier
ausstellungen überrannt werden
möglicherweise teilweise auch soldaten
die waffen niederlegen weil sie wissen
dass sie keine chance haben und die
städte am ende dann sind wir schnell von
separatisten und russen erobert werden
gerade diejenigen die 78 jahre auf der
anderen seite gekämpft haben ich war
dort viele donner 2014 ich habe erlebt
was das für leute sind wir haben
menschen im keller eingesperrt das war
ein macht ja staat das hatte nicht mit
rechtsstaatlichkeit dort zu tun was dort
in dem gebiet passiert ist und diese
menschen diese russischen separatisten
und jetzt die russischen soldaten die
kommen mir dir auch in diese richtung
paul die nato kommt für brüssel zu einer
krisensitzung zusammen bundeskanzler
olaf scholz telefoniert mit dem
ukrainischen präsidenten zielinski und
die letzte meldung und die ukrainische
luftabwehr hat nach haben des
ukrainischen militärs im osten des
landes ein russisches flugzeug
abgeschossen das ist der krieg
das ist krieg seit heute nacht ist krieg
hier eine ost ukraine ist schon länger
krieg aber natürlich nicht in diesem
ausmaß was wir dort erleben das
offizielle russische truppen auf
offizielle ukrainische klub treffen das
ist etwas was auch europa sagt jetzt den
nicht gesehen hat es war vorher
vermeintlich kriege gegen separatisten
die hier stattgefunden haben aber das
ist ein offizieller krieg gerade ein
video gesehen des ukrainischen
präsidenten mit dem ich noch vor einer
woche unterwegs war genau hier in der
region thomas hat ein dramatisches video
aufgenommen hat die menschen
aufgefordert zu hause zu bleiben die
ruhe zu bewahren aber mein gefühl ist
auch wenn hier teilweise die menschen
ganz normal heute morgen zur arbeit
gegangen sind denn sie sind diesen krieg
schon länger gewohnt hier wo ich stehe
da ausdruck verliehen aber die menschen
im ganzen land die ist es schwer dort
die nerven zu behalten alle telefonieren
sind am smartphone versuchen zu erfahren
was jetzt wirklich passiert wie schnell
ihr die russischen truppen kommen
könnten die ukraine hat gegen diese
truppe am ende mittelfristig langfristig
keine chance auch wenn sie ihr ein
flugzeug abgeschossen haben wollen das
ist am ende etwas eine überlegene
russische armee man sehen müssen was
passiert wenn truppen rein kommt dann
kann es passieren das ist hier ganz dann
nochmals zu tun und meine emotionen aber
das zu erleben dass so viele jahre als
reporter hals über kopf doch weil ich
viele freunde aber in der ukraine die
angst um ihr leben haben ich kann deine
emotionen sehr gut nachvollziehen paul
das ist wirklich eine gänsehaut ein
kalter schauer der an den ganzen tag
hier den ganzen morgen über den rücken
läuft das tatsächlich dieser albtraum
wahr zu werden
scheint und viele viele menschen auch in
deutschland um 7 05 an diesem morgen
wenn sie wach werden glauben ihren augen
nicht trauen zu können und ihren ohren
nicht trauen zu können wenn sie
nachrichten wie diese von dir jetzt aus
der ukraine hören aber natürlich sind
die menschen dort jetzt als erstes kann
ja direkt betroffen du hast uns bilder
gezeigt gestern lud miller eine frau in
ärmlichen verhältnissen die versucht
schutz zu finden dort und ja und wenn
man dann weiß dass den menschen keine
hilfe zuteil werden wird dass keiner zu
hilfe kommen wird dann ist das eine
absolut dramatische tragische situation
du bist das später die ludmilla zwei
jahren getroffen eine 62 jahre alte frau
die dort immer wenn beschuss kommt wenn
artilleriebeschuss mörserbeschuss kommt
in diesem keller flüchtet und ich habe
etwas mit genommen gestern von dort ich
habe sie gefragt wo sind ihre kinder und
sehr zügig gesagt meine kinder sind in
russland wir haben kein problem mit
russland ich verstehe nicht was wladimir
putin dort tut hier in der ukraine tut
niemand etwas russen und wir wollen nur
frieden mit unseren nachbarn voll das
ist etwas was mir nicht in den kopf geht
wie man diese beiden völker
gegeneinander aufhetzen kann die so viel
miteinander haben vitali klitschko ein
anderes beispiel sein seine mutter hat
russische vorfahren der vater der
bereits verstorben ist ukrainische
und jetzt erfahren wir dass auf diesen
ton des listen diese politiker diese
prominente stehen die möglicherweise von
russland wird gejagt werden durch die
russische armee und die bevölkerung
nicht versteht was da eigentlich
passiert hier in der ost ukraine
natürlich in den bunkern in den häusern
darin bat man sich an diesem krieg
teilweise gewöhnt ich mittlerweile auch
wieder nach zwei tagen wenn ich
mörserbeschuss höre ich zu kam nicht
mehr richtig zusammen wie vielleicht
vorher aber es ist eine situation die
dazu führt dass man nicht sagen kann in
welche richtung dieses land sich jetzt
in diesen stunden entwickelt es sind die
dunkelsten stunden die dunkelsten
minuten die dunkelsten tage die die
ukraine in den vergangenen jahrzehnten
erlebt hat und auch wir erleben das als
reporter mit
meiner sicht die die schwierig ist sich
auszunehmen und natürlich sind wir
objektiv und natürlich berichten wird
das was ist aber dass ohne emotionen zu
tun und nicht mitgenommen zu sein davon
dass in diesem land plötzlich ich krieg
ausbricht freunde von mir angst haben
dass sie gesagt werden dass sie getötet
werden das ist unmöglich auch als
reporter
und das ist auch völlig in ordnung paul
natürlich es geht um emotionen
letztendlich geht es am ende um nichts
anderes als
emotionen hier
emotionen sind auch angst und auch die
baltischen staaten paul sind in großer
sorge natürlich die grenzen auch an
russland waren teil der sowjetunion sind
jetzt teil der nato und da oben kann es
natürlich auch besonders brenzlig werden
denn sollte einen angriff dort
stattfinden dann würde der so genannte
nato bündnisfall eintreten und dann wäre
in der tat ein ja ein weltkrieg vom zaun
gebrochen lettland hat jetzt aktuell
nato konsultationen nach artikel 4
gefordert also noch nicht nach artikel 5
das wäre der bündnisfall artikel 4 das
heißt es sieht konsultationen vor wenn
ein mitglied meint dass die
unversehrtheit des eigenen territoriums
bedroht seien also große sorge auch dort
wie schnell könnte es zu diesem
flächenbrand kommen
meinst du wie weit würde putin gehen das
ist die frage die sich unsere zuschauer
heute morgen alle stellen
stand jetzt wird putin sich auf die
ukraine konzentrieren das ist schwer
genug für ihn dieses gesamte land wenn
er das denn tatsächlich will so wie es
momentan aussieht und der kontrolle zu
bringen er wird mich direkt weitergeben
dazu starten das halte ich für
ausgeschlossen aber natürlich im nachher
mittelfristiger bald möglicherweise
schon sicherlich die nato schreckt ihn
ab denn der nato bündnisfall würde
bedeuten putin würde krieg mit den usa
mit großbritannien und deutschland
führen das ist etwas anderes als die
ukraine wir haben viel darüber
gesprochen die ukraine ist am ende auf
sich allein gestellt die menschen wurden
guten wurden aufgerufen sich zu melden
hunderttausende an die front zu gehen
und das land zu verteidigen aber auch
das wird gegen die russische armee aus
meiner sicht nicht helfen was da die
weiteren staaten angeht wie sind zurecht
entsorgen wladimir putin hat auch in
seiner rede erkennen lassen vor ja
beitragen drei fragen als er dort
besprochen hat diese wirre rede aus
unserer sicht war darüber gesprochen hat
dass der dass die ukraine das man hier
eigentlich aus seiner sicht kein
existenzrecht hat das dass russland sein
hat er auch über weitere staaten
gesprochen und darüber was das für ein
fehler gewesen sei was die hände der
sowjetunion angeht und viele menschen
experten politiker ja auch in der
ukraine
witali klitschko andere haben es immer
wieder gesagt aus ihrer sicht will putin
die sowjetunion zurück und deswegen
müssen sich natürlich die baltischen
staaten polen natürlich müssen diese
staaten sich große sorgen